And oh, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. When you're diagnosed with cancer, it's a very scary thing.
It's first you don't know who to believe. You're sometimes heard of down a pathway that
later you might regret.
Standards of care are sometimes the right thing to do, going to conventional route with chemotherapy
and radiation of uteropathy. But different cancers can grow at different rates. And often you're told
that this is a very aggressive cancer. We need to attack it right away. But there's always
time to look at adding alternative care to. Alternative care, I wish it wasn't called that because
it should be just daily lifestyle things that you should make changes to when you're diagnosed with
any disease. The disease is there for a reason. We need to investigate why and try to develop a game
plan on what's the best way to deal with it. I know there's a time to incorporate
conventional medicine as well. And we're not against that. But don't think that alternative care
for cancer and conventional medicine are at odds with one another in a sense that you can't do them
together. You can. So adding some alternative things can improve your success rate in any cancers.
Because you're changing the terrain, your body and how you're being able to develop a healthy
immune response to the cancer and protect your healthy cells when you're doing some other
methods like radiation and chemotherapy that can be very damaging to your healthy cells.
But when you do decide to add alternative care, we do understand that it's very confusing. What supplements
should I take? What diet should I do? What should I do? That's what we're here to do is to help
kind of wade through those things for you. We do very specific testing to get your unique protocol.
What specific cancer killers will be good for you? If you look at my book and other books,
there's like a hundred different nutrients that can be good for cancer. We want to test to get
specific so that you're on a couple things. We want to test what foods could be fueling the cancer
and take you off just to those. So you're not making these radical dietary changes that might take
all the joy out of life too. What frequencies to use? What technology to use to help your body target
the cancer? Because ultimately, we want your best success. And no matter what you choose, whether you
choose care with us or whether you just utilize our free book downloads, all our free information here,
understand we're going to be praying for you. We want you ultimately to be obedient to God
and your decision-making process.